the first thing for me as a former
treasury minister also as a constituency
mp
is i know people have been worrying so
much about their energy costs and the
energy bills and the cost of living so
i'm really glad that the first thing liz
truss has done as prime minister is
already make a big announcement about
helping people with the course of energy
through the winter and then today we've
had the announcement on support for
businesses which will be a huge
business will be breathing huge sigh of
relief i think about that and knowing
that they're going to get help through
the winter with the energy costs are you
worried about how to be paid for
oh well of course and you were just
asking me about
friday
uh so what i'm looking forward to seeing
on friday is the chancellor setting out
his plans for economic growth that's a
really big part of his agenda about our
new prime minister's agenda really
really important to the country we've
been through such difficult times we
still are in difficult times but the
best way through anything we know is for
economic growth that's the best thing
for everybody that's how we get higher
wages job opportunities goes through
into people having more money to spend
better stands of living it looks like
we're going to get some tax cuts um some
of them of course have been spoken about
previously and stamp duty is another
that's been floated in the papers today
is now the right time to cut taxes given
high inflation
it's a good question
i would say on inflation clearly we do
have high inflation right now but
looking ahead and the bank of england is
expecting for inflation to
come down uh expecting energy prices to
come down which would be particularly
you know particularly driving uh driving
that and we've got the support with the
cost of energy uh which will help
through the winter on that and then you
know in two years out bank of england is
expecting inflation to come back down to
around about uh two percent and there's
clearly a balance you don't the
government doesn't want to do things
that drive inflation but we also have a
recessionary risk at the moment and we
don't want to see that kind of economic
slowdown
uh we want to see instead of that we
want to see growth so this is exactly
the job for the chancellor
but you accept that tax cuts could fuel
inflation
uh well actually i think you know what
one of the benefits of the decisive
action taken by the prime minister new
chancellor on uh on energy is
that will help uh control inflation and
clearly controlling inflation but on
taxes
it is like the ifs for example says it
you know it could increase inflation
well as i said i mean the the the remit
of the bank of england and its
independence is to take steps uh through
their policies to control inflation and
i just set out um what they're saying
about uh inflation at the moment and i
think we do have against that the
uh the the the risk of
some concern about the recession and the
importance of economic growth so i think
actually you know i think this is a
really really
uh positive agenda um which i'm looking
forward to getting behind
i'm keen to ask about fairness as well
um if you look at some of the policies
that we're seeing from liz truss um
stamp duty cart's corporation tax been
lower than uh planned scrapping the cap
on bankers bonuses is this a government
that looks like it's just on the side of
the wealthy
well the first thing i'd say on that is
actually if you look back over
uh
the last few months uh going back to
around about this time last year last
winter there has been substantial
support put in to help people on lower
incomes this is before
minister though yeah but it's all still
i mean it's worth looking at it in in
the round because these things are
continuing so for instance the support
that was announced before the summer
recess that i was involved in the
treasury in uh developing that package
which is uh 1200 pounds to households on
lower incomes extra help for pensioners
extra 150 pounds of people with
vulnerabilities going out today
what the new prime minister is doing
that these are the policies that she
wants to do stamped due to corporation
tax uh cuts or or cancelling rises
scrapping caps on both those bonuses
it's a valid question how does it well
but i was
just coming to that i'm not saying but i
say do look at it in the round that
those steps have been taken uh
particularly to uh help those on lower
incomes and in fact some of the tax cuts
that have happened over the last year
for instance a universal credit taper
changed essentially a tax cut to those
on lower incomes so those things have
already happened um but clearly the way
that liz truster's prime minister
because he's chancellor are looking this
is then they're really focusing on
economic growth as being the way that
they increase the size of the pie
so overall rather than just saying well
you know there's this is the size of the
uk economy and how do we how do we
redistribute to that amongst people to
say well actually let's look at how we
can invest and how we can uh increase
the size of the uk economy and that
would be good for everybody you
obviously back mushy sunak in the
leadership election you're sitting here
basically because you can do what you
want now you don't have you're not part
of the government any longer um do you
think you're punished by backing the
wrong horse
uh i don't see that at all i mean what i
do see is looking at the cabinet that
liz trust has brought together and
really talented people many of my good
friends very capable people the vast
majority of them who backed out for the
leadership in that cabinet well i mean
it's it's it is a normal thing that uh
somebody who becomes a leader um has
people who are loyal to them and have
helped them
on their journey there um around them i
completely completely understand that
but also really talented colleagues uh
there's real diversity but people are
there because they're merit not because
of uh particularly you know their
background i think that's a real
strength of liz's government and are you
enjoying your newfound freedom so far so
good
okay thank you very much indeed